daniel Jones jersey sales skyrocketed
last Tuesday when he became the Giants
starting quarterback I have a feeling
there will be plenty more than moon
number L&R Z's big sold today 23 for 36
you passes 336 yards two touchdowns no
picks also two touchdowns on the ground
the biggest comeback victory for the
Giants in 49 years first rookie
quarterback with 300 plus passing yards
two passing touchdowns and two rushing
touchdowns in a single game since 1970
oh yeah they're gonna forget about Eli
Manning quickly if this guy keeps going
now it's one game yeah but down 28 10 at
the half yeah how many times have we
seen this movie play out for any team
right that's a big deficit to overturn
and and I thought of you last night yeah
see the link I sent you know what the
catalyst I did not list for the giant I
didn't know I didn't look at Daniel
jones working blue big blue work and
blue with the f-bombs he went nuts heap
he used some of Chris Sims favorite word
hey and it's and it surprised his
teammates I mean think about it 15 years
of Eli Manning who I don't think could
say the f-word if he tried here's daniel
Jones latinum fly in his first game and
let me tell you that is a real concept I
know there have been quarterbacks that
their coaches have desperately tried to
get them to yeah angry you know Rudin is
sure done here Chris and you have to do
it didn't go you know hey get the hell
get you know yeah right now thank you
for that's the PG version yes please the
team does feed off a life and from the
quarterback whether it's like yelling
from the quarterback like oh come on we
got to get our crap together and here's
you know something to say to put the
poker on your butt to get everybody
playing or just the energy they bring to
the field in general and that's the
thing that I thought jumped out from the
get-go with Danielle Jones I mean they
their offense looks so much better with
Daniel Jones and I don't mean to say
that just sit here and crap on Eli
Manning and then he you know provide any
stretch of the imagination the simple
fact of the matter is Daniel Jones he
stands in the pocket and takes big hits
he was aggressive looking for throws
on the field and his movement is very
good as we saw he can run and turn the
corner and they can move the pocket with
him and they were a different offense
with Daniel Jones a quarterback it was
pretty evident yeah and you had
mentioned is Eli Manning gonna look at
some of the plays that they've used and
the way they're running the offense and
wonder why the hell didn't they do that
with me I mean maybe they assess his
current skills and abilities and say
yeah with you right it would Jones yeah
I think he'll I might have sat over
there yesterday and gone wow okay yeah
they can run some of these I was the
problem they can run some of these plays
because because of this guy at
quarterback and he's special that way
but either way what a special special
game for Daniel Jones to win it that way
after all the scrutiny took for being
the number six pick and now to where he
is now he's he's in a different
stratosphere in New York sport and and
they should have lost it all came down
to the missed field goal by the
Buccaneers that that should have been
met either way it was a great
performance by him we'd still be
impressed yes but it wouldn't feel as
special if you don't emerge you'd be a
little tarnish yeah you don't get a
victory but still he passed the test and
off goes the daniel Jones era teddy
bridgewater back yep for the first time
since the 2015 playoffs as a guy who
comes in as the guy and and and you know
the thing that impressed me about Teddy
Bridgewater when we've seen him play in
recent years it has not been
overwhelming yeah but he got it done not
big numbers 19 to 20 777 yards two
touchdowns Saints only had 265 yards of
offense I got a couple of touchdowns
pick return fumble return touchdown and
the Seahawks head over 500 yards yeah
and still lost that game right but hey
they got it done they got the win they
stole one I thought that the Seahawks
would win this one easily and maybe the
Seahawks did too well yeah and they'd
certainly took him lightly I mean the
Saints really did what Seattle does to
people most the times up there in
Seattle I mean I like saying the the
Saints out Seattle Seattle in Seattle
you like that one I mean that's what
they did they kind of said oh we'll just
out hit you and out-hustle you and we'll
win special teams and we'll cause a few
turnovers that's usually what Seattle
does to opponent it's kind of fun to see
them get their own medicine
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports